hey
wait wait wait hey
that's good okay we're back it's katie
and this is my husband chris hi so i'm
very excited because disney has been
releasing some of their most famous
recipes that's exciting including
the churros
guys i love gyros
the churros at disneyland are just so
perfect they're crunchy they're sweet so
i'm gonna test this recipe and chris you
could be the taste tester and we can see
if it actually tastes like the park
churro i'm very excited i am sure
they're gonna be great also my friend
jasmine on the bring me channel is
testing out some of these recipes as
well so go check her out i'm gonna get
started i'll bring you back in and we
can do a taste test now arriving snack
town usa where all the snacks are
maybe
all right so i have everything together
i'm ready to test this churro something
to note is i was reading the recipe and
it says it was inspired by the disney
park churro which could mean that this
isn't exactly what they do at the parks
it's also churro bites not the long
churro
kind of disappointing but maybe the
taste will just be like so amazing it
won't matter let's dive in and see how
this goes first thing we're gonna do is
put our pan over medium high heat and
then we're gonna combine water
eight tablespoons of butter a quarter
teaspoon of cinnamon and a quarter
teaspoon of salt combine this once your
butter has melted you're gonna wait till
it gets to a rolling boil and then
you're gonna turn it down to low once
it's low we're gonna combine a cup and a
quarter of flour and mix that together
until it becomes a ball
i think that looks like a ball turn the
heat off and the recipe says to let it
rest for five to seven minutes all right
my dough's been resting for about seven
minutes it's cool to the touch now so
i'm going to add in these eggs one by
one mix that one egg in there until it's
fully incorporated and then you'll move
on to the next one basically what the
churro dough is is a choux pastry that
we're then gonna fry and a choux pastry
is very simple you use it in like cream
puffs or a croquenbouche that's a big
fancy french dessert rye has made it but
it's the same kind of base for the dough
we're adding eggs because that's going
to bring structure to this dough and
also give it a nice rich flavor
okay that was a workout
next we're going to add a cup and a half
of oil heat this up to 350 degrees over
medium-high heat so while this is coming
up to temperature i'm gonna put the
dough in a piping bag and i'm using a
rather large open star tip but if you
only have a gallon plastic bag you can
just cut the corner of that and that can
be your piping bag whatever works
that's what i always say
[Music]
the next step disney tells you to do a
little later but i'm going to do it
right now so over to my left i have a
baking pan with paper towels and that's
why i can put the churros on it to sop
up some of the oil after they've been
fried and i'm also going to mix my sugar
and my cinnamon right next to it all
right and i'm all done with my sugar so
now
the recipe says to pipe in one inch
churros and then use a knife to cut them
off the ends
and just make sure you roll them over so
that they are all getting kind of evenly
coated i feel like this is all that i
can manage at a time right now is about
six in the pan you could maybe get a few
more but
i it stressed me out too much to have
any more churros than that in here
these guys look good
let's get them out of the oil we'll just
set them down and we're gonna coat them
in cinnamon and sugar
[Music]
okay these are looking delicious and i'm
just gonna give one a try before we even
call chris
these are really yummy but they don't
taste like the parks i i feel like
there's something missing on the inside
the outside is sweet and crunchy and
perfect but the inside is definitely
missing something
hi hi
i'm calling because i made the disney
recipe and i know that you make churros
like all the time and i'm wondering what
you what goes inside your like pastry
probably some sugar
sugar you put sugar in
yours being recorded right now yep like
you're gonna edit this out it's not live
tv i'm just calling you
okay
i definitely think you need a little
sugar about two tablespoons i think that
you've helped solve the
the missing element bye
bye i miss you
i really think adding some sugar to this
recipe is gonna make a huge difference
and if it doesn't then at least i did
all the work and you guys didn't have to
so we'll find out so i'm basically gonna
do everything i did before and i'm gonna
add those two tablespoons of sugar to
really help make this dough fabulous
all right our piping bag is ready to go
and the next thing i'm going to change
is the size of the churro i totally get
why they did the little bites it's
perfect it's super practical for being
at home but i am not being practical
today i am trying to create
magic i want i want to feel like i'm at
disneyland so instead i'm gonna pipe
them onto this pan freeze them so i can
just pick them up and plop them in the
frying oil
i think they look pretty good some are
straighter than others but they look
alright like this guy looks he looks
good he's the hero i'm gonna go put
these in the freezer and we'll be back
to heat up the oil
wow i know not everyone has a pan this
huge so if you don't you could always
try baking your churros in the oven so
we're gonna add two and a half cups of
oil to the pan all right our oil is at
350
and
and our churros have frozen up so i'm
gonna gently pick them up and
set them in oh
it just fits across
we might only be able to do one or two
at a time if these can be held by hand
like they do at disney that will be a
triumph
but i'm afraid
that they're gonna flop and if you're
doing this at home ever and they're
getting too brown too quick you could
always finish them up in the oven so
that they don't burn in the oil now this
guy set them down all right that guy
broke
we'll let that cool down for a second
here and once it's cooled a little bit
we're gonna move it onto our cinnamon
sugar and coat that all over
since the freeze method only worked so
well i'm gonna try to pipe some of these
directly into the frying pan i have some
leftover i might as well
[Music]
honestly the ones that i piped out
into the frying oil look better than the
ones i froze they the ones i froze got
thin and kind of lost their luster okay
oh
it's staying together while i'm holding
it chris
it's time to test some churros
it looks awesome i'm very excited at
what i'm seeing here you're probably
also very confused i'm a little confused
yeah there's multiple churro options
here the one on the left is the churro
bite recipe disney released it's tiny
it's practical and the one on the right
are the experimental ones where i was
trying to get that classic disney look
and i changed one thing in the recipe i
eat these all at once right i just like
just like
scooby doo style
it is slightly different though than the
park it's not exactly like the park it's
not but they're really good they are
they're still very good let's try the
second version oh wow disney style thank
you so much now this feels like i'm at a
theme park
[Music]
so this one definitely tastes
closer the secret ingredient was sugar i
added sugar
secret ingredient
it doesn't taste like the park though
they still have not revealed all of
their magic they're keeping some secrets
disney you need to release the real rest
release the real release the recipe
flash mountain pose when you go down
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
you